servus aus Nürnberg willkommen zur
kneipp-wahl ich bin nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt von dem Wahlbezirk der bei der
letzten Landtagswahl in Bayern die
niedrigste Wahlbeteiligung hatte kann es
sein dass Menschen nicht wählen weil sie
ihre eigenen Themen zu wenig abgebildet
sind wir befinden uns in einer Zeit
voller Krisen klimakrieg Inflation ich
will wissen welche Themen junge Menschen
im Bundesland Bayern bewegen deshalb
habe ich drei von ihnen eingeladen die
uns ihre Geschichten erzählen momentan
haben wir schon 100 Asylbewerber
aufgenommen und es soll noch mal 100
dazu kommen Gesellschaft mit so viel
Hass und deshalb haben wir ein Projekt
gegründet das nennt sich wir sind wir
haben einen erheblichen Fachkräftemangel
der auf den Rücken aller getragen wird
[Musik]
drei Bayerinnen und Bayern werden uns
gleich ihre Geschichten und Forderungen
vorstellen in den kneipenrad habe ich
Menschen aus dem ganzen Bundesland
eingeladen und natürlich auch
Stammpublikum aus dieser Kneipe hier sie
werden entscheiden welches Thema Ihnen
am wichtigsten ist
hallo ich bin Eva schön dass Ihr alle
hier seid wir sind zusammengekommen zur
kneipenwall in Nürnberg und das sind
Melanie aus Lenggries Markus aus München
und Francesca aus Erlangen ihr alle habt
jeweils ein Thema mitgebracht von dem
ihr sagt das ist das Wichtigste was
Bayern momentan bewegen sollte und wo
sich ganz dringend was ändern muss die
Regeln von der kneipenwahl sind
eigentlich ganz einfach jeder von den
dreien bekommt gleich eine Minute Zeit
um euch den kneipenrad von seinem Thema
zu überzeugen und deutlich zu machen
okay das ist das worüber es ganz
dringend eine Doku braucht denn ich
werde nur eins von diesen Themen nehmen
und weiß selber noch nicht was mich
diesen Sommer beschäftigen wird das wird
hier ganz demokratisch von euch
entschieden Melanie schön dass du da
bist du hast eine Minute überzeugt den
kneipenrad ab jetzt ich bin Melanie 28
aus momentan haben wir schon 100
Asylbewerber aufgenommen und es soll
noch mal 100 dazu kommen
ich bin auch absolut dafür nur es macht
mir ein bisschen Angst einfach die ganze
Situation wie wir das noch
bewerkstelligen sollen im Bekanntenkreis
bekommen andere Mütter in den Kita an
keine Plätze mehr die Ärzte sind alle
ausgeschöpft und auch ich selbst habe
ein Jahr lang gebraucht bis ich eine
Wohnung gefunden habe bei meinem Vater
zum Beispiel arbeitet auch ein Asylant
den ich gerne über unterstütze und auch
geholfen hat mit zu integrieren ich
wünsche mir dass meine Stimme von
mehreren gehört wird super vielen Dank
dass du das mit uns
was ist die größte Sorge die du mit
diesem Thema Einwanderung und
geflüchteten verbindest das wäre einfach
mit der Masse nicht mehr fertig werden
also es ist so oder so dass einfach für
die Gemeinde selber schon die Kapazität
eigentlich schon auf Anschlag ist eben
wie der Kita Plätzen Wohnraum und
natürlich
[Musik]
sollen die mit integriert werden aber
wie wir das noch machen sollen wenn es
eh schon alles auf Anschlag ist einfach
ja dann vielen Dank
und Markus deine Minute beginnt jetzt hi
servus ich bin Markus den 30 Jahre alt
schwul und Maschinenbauingenieur und
auch Drag Queen vielleicht habt ihr es
mitbekommen zusammen mit dem Münchner
Stadtbibliotheken habe ich als Wiki
voyage eine drag Lesung für Familien mit
Kindern organisiert in der es darum ging
für Freiheit zu werden dass jeder
einfach sein kann wie er möchte und
leider ist uns im Vorfeld sehr viel Hass
entgegengeschlagen vor allem online da
kamen Kommentare wie hände weg von
unseren Kindern ihr kommt doch aus dem
rotlichtmühle geht dahin zurück oder ihr
seid doch alle Pädophile und es geht
sogar bis zum morddrohnen und auch die
Kinder die in den verarschen in der
Veranstaltung waren haben von ihren
Erlebnissen im Kindergarten z.B erzählt
wo manche Kindergärtnerin sagen wenn ein
Junge lange Haare hat darf er nicht mehr
auf jungen Klo gehen und da freue ich
mich wohin als Gesellschaft mit so viel
Hass und deshalb hat man mir ein Projekt
gegründet das nennt sich quer und wir 13
Persönlichkeiten aus der Klienten Welt
erzählen was sie unter quier-netzt
verstehen warum sie wie sie leben und
was sie sich von Politik und
Gesellschaft
unter anderem
unintelligible
zu Ende aber ich glaube du hattest es
auch genau was wäre so die eine
Veränderung die du dir wünschen würdest
wo man im Alltag merken würde dass
Bayern bunter diverser offener ist was
wir brauchen ist eben der kläre
Aktionsplan in Bayern ist das einzige
Bundesland in Deutschland was kein
virenaktionsplan hat was glaube ich am
wichtigsten ist es dass es einfach ein
Angebot gibt für Lehrkräfte für Familien
für die Kinder auch wie gehe ich um wenn
ich als Elternteil in ihres Kind habe
was vielleicht daran ist was mache ich
als Lehrer an der Schule oder als
Lehrerin wenn ich in einem
Klassenverbund einfach Menschen habe die
ein bisschen anders sind damit in
Zukunft kein Mobbing mehr ist okay danke
dass du das Thema mit
so und unsere dritte Kandidatin ist
Francesca aus Erlangen Franziska deine
Minute beginnt jetzt ich bin die
Francesca bin 26 und stellvertretende
Leitungen im Kindergarten wir haben 60
Kinder dort im Kindergarten die wir
momentan zu fünf betreuen wir haben
einen erheblichen Fachkräftemangel der
auf den Rücken aller getragen wird also
nicht nur von uns die wir uns müde und
erschöpft arbeiten und total überlastet
sind sondern auch auf deren Kinder wir
können nicht mehr voll in dem Umfang wie
wir gerne hätten auf die Bedürfnisse und
die Entwicklungsstandard der Kinder
eingehen wir können
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig
arbeiten wie wir es möchten wir können
ja nicht mehr richtig fördern und wer
noch darunter leidet sind natürlich auch
die Eltern in dem Moment in dem wir eine
Person weniger im Moment sind rutschen
wir in eine Notbetreuung wir können die
Betreuung der Kinder nicht mehr komplett
gewährleisten das funktioniert nicht
mehr als Fachkraft darf ich 12,5 Kinder
betreuen zu fünft Sommer summarum 62,5
10 Kinder würden wenn eine Person
ausfällt also schon nicht mehr Betreuung
sieht
ich hoffe das war der letzte Satz danke
wie könnte denn eine größere
Wertschätzung aussehen was würdest du
dir da wünschen es liegt nicht am Beruf
es liegt schon an der Ausbildung ich
hätte diese Ausbildung nicht machen
können wenn ich nicht den Willen dazu
gehabt hätte okay ich beantrage jetzt
Bafög halbweißen Rente und macht zwei
Nebenjobs damit ich mir das leisten kann
weil Kinderpflege ist nicht für gütet in
Ausbildung ist eine schulische
Ausbildung danke dass du das mitgebracht
hast
ihr habt jetzt ein bisschen Zeit euch
darüber Gedanken zu machen und dann
werden wir gleich abstimmen per
Handzeichen
[Musik]
wer hat dich denn gerade am meisten
überzeugt
ich bin Unentschlossenheit wir haben
gerade zum Eiweiß aber ich glaube der
dritte Punkt also die contestka der muss
wirklich was gemacht werden weil wir
eigentlich verstehen müssen dass Kinder
die Zukunft sind die fehlende quernes
die ist in Bayern gibt ist ein absolut
ja doch wichtiges Thema es gibt halt
auch noch eine gewisse konservative
Mehrheit die da Probleme mit hat ich bin
eigentlich eher für das Thema ja
Migrationspolitik dass man dafür macht
weil ich merke jetzt auch in den letzten
Jahren die Stimmung im Land ist sehr
aufgehalten
[Musik]
vielen Dank an euch dass ihr diese drei
Themen mitgebracht hat die in Bayern ja
wirklich heißt debattiert werden und ich
bin auch ganz gespannt was mich jetzt
den Sommer über beschäftigen wird
deswegen kommen wir zur Abstimmung und
wir gehen der Reihe nach durch und
Stimmen per Handzeichen ab wie gesagt
jeder von euch hat genau eine Stimme und
wir fangen an mit der Frage die Melanie
mitgebracht hat nämlich wie in Bayern
künftig Asyl und Migrationspolitik
gestaltet werden soll so dass wir
Menschen so habe ich dich verstanden es
war noch willkommen heißen aber
gleichzeitig unsere Systeme nicht
überlasten wer sagt darüber muss es
unbedingt eine Doku geben da wollt ihr
mich losschicken
[Musik]
dort auch noch sechs dann gehen wir an
Thema Nummer zwei das Markus mitgebracht
hat der sagt Bayern muss offener werden
für quebe Menschen es braucht einen
Aktionsplan und wie können wir Toleranz
in diesem Bereich stärken
[Musik]
10 okay und dann frage ich jetzt noch zu
Thema Nummer 3 Francesca sagt
Fachkräftemangel die Kitas da müssen wir
ansetzen da gehen viele Hände hoch
auf 25 komme ich das heißt es ist eine
eindeutige Mehrheit wir haben eine
eindeutige Gewinnerin ein eindeutiges
Gewinner Thema das ist Francesca
herzlichen Glückwunsch
das heißt wir werden uns wiedersehen und
euch beide wenn wir aber auch
Wiedersehen wenn euch also die Themen
von Markus und Melanie interessieren
dann verfolgt unsere Instagram und
tiktok Kanäle und ansonsten sage ich
herzlichen Dank an den kneipenrad für
eure Entscheidung dass ihr heute dabei
wart es bleibt spannend
[Applaus]
okay wow ich hätte nie gedacht dass die
Abstimmung im bayerischen kneipenrad so
eindeutig ausfällt aber damit habe ich
jetzt ja auch eine klare Mission also
die Wochen vor der bayerischen
Landtagswahl werde ich mich mit dem
Fachkräftemangel in Bayern beschäftigen
das ist aber auch ein ganz schön
vielschichtiges Thema und deswegen will
ich mich in dieser Reportage auf
Fachkräfte in der Kita und in anderen
sogenannten Sorge gerufen konzentrieren
was sind da die größten Probleme und
Bedürfnisse und betrifft uns das nicht
irgendwie alle da will ich jetzt tiefer
eintauchen und so hoffentlich mehr
Aufmerksamkeit auch bei der Politik
generieren zunächst treffe ich die
Erzieherin Francesca in ihrer Kita
wieder
[Musik]
hallo
und ist das abseits von Geburtstag heute
so ein ganz normale Arbeitstag für dich
ja also abgesehen davon dass wir
heute ein bisschen die Betreuungszeit
anpassen mussten weil eine Kollegin
ausgefallen ist die wurde jetzt operiert
ich muss mich gleich und dementsprechend
mussten wir jetzt so umswitchen dass wir
gesagt haben dass alle nachmittagskräfte
die eigentlich nachmittags bei uns
arbeiten jetzt am Vormittag kommen damit
wir geöffnet halten können und nicht in
den Notbetreuung rutschen weil gestern
war der Kindergarten größtenteils
geschlossen das heißt ich komme auch an
so einem typischen Tag wo kommst an
einem ganz typischen Tag ich war gestern
so kurz davor für heute abzusagen weil
ihr so wenige sind und das heißt heute
Nachmittag werden all diese Kinder
abgeholt ob sie ihre Eltern bis gestern
damit gerechnet haben genau also wir
haben quasi jetzt heute bis um 14 Uhr
geöffnet hat
genau zwei zwei ja und wie heißt die
Zahl weißt du das auch
die zwei und
22 genau
[Musik]
was würdest du sagen könnte die größten
Herausforderungen im Kita Alter ja
gerade wenn man alleine ist dann ist
natürlich dann sind so die einfachsten
Sachen die natürlich irgendwie einen
Aufwand dann ähm wann gehe ich wickeln
wer kommt mein Kindern während ich
wickelt die oder zu meinen Kindern wenn
ich sage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also Teller stehen lassen die Flaschen
in die flaschenbox die nehmen wir mit
raus Niklas cappies nicht vergessen und
Schuhe laut einer Studie aus dem Jahr
2022 fehlen in Bayern
62.000 Kitaplätze und
14.500 Erzieher und Erzieherin um die
Kinder zu betreuen
jetzt sind wir so kurz vor der
Landtagswahl bald kommt eine neue
Regierung was würdest du dir von der
wünschen also definitiv bin ich der
Meinung dass einfach mehr Fokus auf
sozial Gesundheits- und Bildungswesen
gesetzt werden müsste wie finanzieren
Branchen die eh schon
massig Geld haben also diese großen
Konzerne sage ich einfach mal den geben
wir noch mehr aber da wo es dringend
nötig ist Fachkräfte mit an Land ziehen
einfach die Verdienste anzupassen da
wird wieder
gesparty das ist lieb dass du sie da so
unterstützt bringt dir mal in wie weit
lösen so gesellschaftliche Entwicklung
wie die Pandemie oder auch Zuwanderung
zum zusätzlichen Druck bei euch aus klar
war Corona anstrengend und hat andere
Herausforderungen mit sich gebracht aber
das wo wir jetzt drin sind diese
Fachkräftemangel wo ich sage dafür in
Bezugspersonen da fehlt mir Sicherheit
da fehlten Anker das finde ich noch viel
schlimmer muss ich ehrlich sein weil das
wenn ich ein Kind annehme das gerade
Schwierigkeiten hat und das nächste
kommt und hat auch Schwierigkeiten und
ich muss eigentlich dann zu dem anderen
Kind das vertrösten oder das Bedürfnis
von dem Kind kann ich in dem Moment
nicht stillen und das kann ich teilweise
nicht mehr weil ich eben alleine bin
weil ich Kinder vertrösten muss weil ich
sagen muss hey gerade echt schlecht muss
später noch mal kommen und manchmal
kommen die Kinder dann nicht mehr
Haare
hallo hallo
[Musik]
merkt ihr als Eltern dass ihr zu wenig
Personal ist schon also die Sarah sagt
öfter zu Hause heute war sie alleine
oder das und das hat nicht stattgefunden
das merkt sie natürlich was für
Auswirkungen hat das auf dich und euch
als Familie ganz konkret also das ist
nur mit unglaublich viel hin und her
organisiere rein und ganz ganz viel
Verständnis und Hilfe vom Arbeitgeber
wenn der Arbeitgeber sich querstellen
würde hätte ich keine Chance
[Musik]
das aber witzige ist ja auch statt
schneller Lösungen für den
Fachkräftemangel hat Ministerpräsident
Markus Söder noch nicht vorgeschlagen
dass Kinder mit schlechteren
Deutschkenntnissen noch länger in die
Kita gehen sollen das heißt mehr Kinder
anstatt schneller Entlastung für
Francesco
[Musik]
die CSU mit ihrem traditionellen
Rollenverständnis von Familie stellt in
Bayern seit mehr als einem halben
Jahrhundert den Ministerpräsidenten doch
inwieweit Familienpolitik hier im
Freistaat tatsächlich in den Vordergrund
gestellt wird wird meine nächste Station
zeigen
ich bin unterwegs nach Starnberg der
Landkreis ist einer der reichsten
Deutschlands aber eins ist hier absolute
Mangelware Kitaplätze unzählige Eltern
warten auf einen Platz für ihre Kinder
weil Personal fehlt gerade hat eine Kita
ihre Schließung verkündet Rebeccas Kind
wurde hier betreut alle Erzieherinnen
waren am Limit und haben gekündigt warum
kündigen denn die Erzieherinnen hier
durch die Arbeitsbelastung das ist keine
Seltenheit das ein Erzieherin alleine
den ganzen Tag in der Einrichtung ist
oder in einer Gruppe was einfach
physisch und psychisch nicht mehr
auszuhalten ist ja und ihr als Eltern
seid dann zum Teil eingesprungen und
habe mit die erzieherdienste übernommen
genau wir haben eine Elterninitiative
gegründet vor dem Hintergrund dass wir
eigentlich gestartet sind indem wir in
Eltern notfallpool gegründet haben wo
wir eingesprungen sind dass dann eben
Eltern da waren um einfach die
Erzieherinnen die denn noch da ist zu
entlasten zu unterstützen und
tatsächlich wurden wir regelmäßig
freitags angerufen wo wir dann nach dem
fünften Freitag dann auch gesagt haben
also wir sind notfallpool wir möchten
aber nicht in der Personalplanung
aufgenommen werden
rebecca ist als Unternehmensberaterin
dringend auf einen Kita-Platz angewiesen
braucht diesen für 35 Stunden die Woche
wie kann das sein dass einerseits Kitas
hier schließen müssen und andererseits
allein im Landkreis Starnberg mehrere
hundert Kinder auf der Warteliste für
einen Kitaplatz stehen das fragt sich
auch der Landrat Stefan frei der hat
sich neulich schon
öffentlichkeitswirksam an die bayerische
Familienministerin gewagt Herr frei ich
komme gerade aus einer leerstehenden
Kita hier in ihrem Landkreis
gleichzeitig stehen hunderte Kinder auf
der Warteliste für Kitaplätze wie kann
das sein noch dazu in einem der
reichsten Landkreise Deutschlands ja wir
heben uns da gar nicht ab von anderen
Landkreisen die Menschen die hier leben
viele Menschen haben viel Geld aber wir
haben die gleichen Sorgen und Nöte wie
andere Kommunen bei uns sind momentan
230 Kinderkrippen und ca 210
Kindergartenplätze nicht vermittelbar
bei uns schlicht die Leute fehlen da
können Sie schöne Gebäude bauen da
können sie ja auch investieren aber was
nicht da ist nicht da
[Musik]
die Familienministerin die von ihrer
gleichen Partei kommt auch aus der CSU
die sagt Fachkräftemangel das ist kein
Problem das ist in fünf Jahren passé
weil wir schon genug Maßnahmen ergriffen
haben aber da sind sie offenbar anderer
Meinungen also dieses
Rundum-Sorglos-Paket das werden wir
nicht bekommen und da muss man auch ein
Stück weit den Eltern die Realität sagen
das wird ein langer Prozess werden und
Politik kann Rahmenbedingungen setzen
dazu gehört mehr Geld dazu gehören auch
in gewisser Weise die Abdeckung von
Standards mehr Quereinsteiger ins System
holen und dann glaube ich könnten wir
das hinbekommen die Bundesregierung hat
dieses Jahr ja eingesetzt verabschiedet
mit der sie vor einem Fachkräfte aus dem
Ausland anziehen und es denen hier
leichter machen will der bayerische
Ministerpräsident auch CSU wie sie hat
aber im Bundesrat dagegen gestimmt die
erklären Sie sich das es nutzt Ihnen
eine ausländische Fachkraft nicht wenn
sie kein Deutsch spricht und wenn wir
sagen wir wollen weniger Bürokratie
dann ist es letztlich auch von Seiten
des Bundes notwendig nicht mehr
Ansprüche zu schaffen nur weil das
Gesetz ja auch Bürokratie abbauen und
uns den Leuten leichter machen
ganz ehrlich wenn ich ich bekomme jeden
Tag vom Bund derzeit gesetzespakete
fragen Sie mal die Leute die arbeiten ob
das noch jemand versteht was davon oben
kommt da muss ich auch sagen meilenweit
verfehlt auch seitens der
Bundesregierung meilenweit
man bekommt den Eindruck dass die
verschiedenen politischen Ebenen hier
alle irgendwie mit dem Finger
aufeinander zeigen die sind sich das
Problems zwar bewusst aber wenn selbst
der Landrat sagt dass die Menschen ihre
Ansprüche runterschrauben müssen dann
ist erstmal kein Ende der Belastung in
sicht weder für Familien noch für
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher
was das wiederum für Auswirkungen auf
Erzieherinnen die Francesca hat erzählt
sie mir zu Hause
wie geht's dir denn jetzt nach so einem
Arbeitstag in der Kita ja also
grundsätzlich ist bei mir schon so
ein Ding dass ich einfach nicht
abschalten kann weil es für mich
trotzdem in meinem hören so okay wie
geht's jetzt den Eltern mit der
Situation den Rest der Woche ist ja auch
so dass wir früher schließen müssen und
ja da bist Du halt schon mit den
Gedanken noch irgendwo in der Arbeit und
wie wird der nächste Tag fehlt noch
jemand aus ähm was passiert wenn jemand
ausfällt wie handeln wir dann können wir
es noch stemmen kann uns irgendwer noch
aushelfen von den anderen man schaltet
irgendwie ein bisschen nie ab das ist
schon schwer es ist aber ja noch ein
bisschen was vom Tag übrig was machst Du
denn damit vielleicht auch jetzt zum
Runterkommen noch mal Gitarre spielen
schauen ob es neue Lieder gibt oder
irgendwas was zum Thema passt was man
gerade noch
eingeführt hat und dann
ja übe ich halt Gitarre okay mit dem
Kopf bist du trotzdem noch in der Kita
dann mitunter
[Musik]
kannst du dir vorstellen diesen Beruf
dein Leben lang zu machen ich würde
schon behaupten ich mache das bis ich
Umfallen aber macht mein Körper mit und
wann falle ich um das ist eher so die
Frage und ist das hin und Zweck der
Sache sich da so tot zu arbeiten
allein für die Kinder also das ist ja
auch der Anspruch den ich an mir selbst
habe das ist ja auch einer der Gründe
warum ich den Job mache was müsste sich
dann an den Arbeitsbedingungen ändern
damit dein Arbeitgeber dich bis zur
Rente halten kann also 4 Tage Woche wäre
schon denke ich einfach so ein erster
Schritt und das ganze mal ein bisschen
zu entfernen sondern lassen wenn man
sieht ja auch einen anderen Ländern dass
es fruchtig Produktivität hochsteigt
dass die Leute weniger krank sind ja es
wäre schon wünschenswert
unausreichende Bezahlung und enorme
psychische Belastung das was Francesca
da beschreibt das ist ja nicht nur ein
Problem von Erzieherinnen und Erziehern
sondern zieht sich durch ganz viele
verschiedene sorgeber Berufe die Pflege
zum Beispiel da heißt es dann immer eine
vier Tage Woche oder generell flexiblere
Arbeitszeiten das sei einfach nicht drin
aber stimmt das das Uniklinikum Würzburg
hat vor einigen Monaten ein Flex Modell
eingeführt die gehen jetzt ganz
individuell auf die Bedürfnisse von
jeder Pflegerin jedem Flieger ein kann
das die Lösung sein für den
Fachkräftemangel das schaue ich mir
jetzt an
[Musik]
morgen oder hallo hallo ich kenne zu
lernen
bzw wie lange arbeitest du überhaupt
schon ich dokumentiere jetzt gerade
meine Arbeit die ich von heute morgen
gemacht habe ich bin seit 6 Uhr auf
Station und genau dann ist die halbe
Schicht schon rum wahrscheinlich
sozusagen ich würde dich ja richtig
gerne heute mal einen Tag begleiten weil
ich gehört habe dass du hier in diesem
neuen Flex Modell arbeite genau
[Musik]
kannst du mir mal erklären du arbeitest
jetzt hier im Flex Modell was genau
bedeutet das also im Prinzip haben wir
flexible Arbeitszeiten flexible
Einsatzorte wir können im Prinzip unsere
Arbeitszeiten komplett frei wählen wir
können sagen wir wollen nur eine Schicht
machen nur zwei Schichten alle drei
Schichten wir können unsere Dienstzeiten
anpassen also auch den Frühdienst zum
Beispiel später starten damit es mit mir
Familienleben vereinbar ist genau und
wir können uns eben raussuchen auf
welche Stationen wir arbeiten wollen das
heißt du springst zwischen 15 Stationen
in deinem Alltag es kann sein Morgen
bist du auf Station a übermorgen auf
Station B ja zufällig unterschiedlichen
Zeiten das ist der Kern von diesem Flex
genau wie war das für dich bevor du in
dieses Flex Modell gewechselt bist dass
du auch schon jahrelang als Pflegerin
gearbeitet ich habe eben auch auf einer
inneren Station gearbeitet auf einer
Onkologie habe da auch alle Schichten
gemacht das war ohne Kind auch alles
möglich bin dann aber auch oft an meine
Grenzen angekommen ich bin oft von der
Arbeit nach Hause habe geweint konnte
einfach nicht mehr die Familie hat
runtergelitten die das der Freundeskreis
man hat was ausgemacht und hat das
Telefon geklingelt dann hat man
niemanden gefunden dann ist man halt
selber eingesprungen ja und das alles
fällt jetzt weg
im Klinikum Würzburg sind 7% der
Mitarbeitenden im Pflegebereich flexibel
angestellt dabei können Sie Ihren
Dienstplan und übergeordnete
Arbeitsbereiche selbst bestimmen sarah
hat zwar kein festes Team aber
wiederkehrende Stationen und wird als
Springerin eingesetzt
das ist eine onkologische Station das
heißt Krebspatientin genau
ist bei uns noch weiterhin maskenpflicht
weil die Patienten einfach durch die
Chemotherapie ziemlich geschwächtes
Immunsystem haben
hallo
ich habe heute die Eva mitgebracht die
schaut mir mal ein bisschen über die
Schulter heute
so jetzt vom Kreislauf
geht
brauchen Sie noch eine Sekunde
helf ihnen rüber dass sie
ich fand es gerade ganz interessant du
hast gemerkt dass der Patient ein Moment
länger einfach braucht dass sie sich
dass sie kurz Luft holen mussten mal und
die Stellen mir vor das was man auch
sonst von anderen Pflegenden hört das
genau das sonst gar nicht mehr drin ist
weil alles so eng getaktet ist und man
so viel zu tun hat und so im Stress ist
ist das ein Unterschied hast du früher
anders arbeiten müssen definitiv ja also
es gibt auch noch Tage im flexpool die
definitiv sehr stressig sind aber ich
muss sagen dadurch dass ich wirklich
oft die Lücken Fülle und ähm oder
teilweise auch zusätzlich geplant bin
habe ich definitiv mehr Zeit holen Sie
sich aus Erdinger okay machen sie die
Augen noch ein bisschen zu und Knochen
sie durch und wenn sie was brauchen
sagen sie Bescheid okay
[Musik]
aber das heißt wenn ich es richtig
verstehe wenn dieses Flex Modell nicht
eingeführt worden wäre dann hätte dieses
Klinikum und hätte das System
Krankenhaus dich als Pflegekraft
verloren vermutlich ja für mich ist es
tatsächlich so dass ich dadurch die
Qualität meiner Arbeit verbessert hat
weil ich nicht mehr motiviert war man
ist vielleicht nicht Teil des festen
Teams aber man kennt sich man kennt
gerade in der Onkologie die Patienten
kommen immer wieder die kommen in zwei
Wochen vier Wochen Zyklen immer wieder
zur Chemo man kennt auch die irgendwann
was war der Impuls hier dieses Flex
Modell einzuführen und wir haben
natürlich wir alle Branchen in
Deutschland hier auch Pflegedienst am
Uni kilikum in Würzburg erheblichen
Fachkräftemangel und wir brauchten
innovative Konzepte wenn uns zum Produkt
zu Beginn dieses Projekt ist jemand
gesagt hätte ihr bekommt innerhalb von
gut acht Monaten letzten Endes fast 600
Bewerbungen aus denen sich dann eben ja
210 Stellen ergeben das hätte keiner
geglaubt
ich würde jetzt noch zu einer Patienten
gehen die ein bisschen mobilisieren mit
ihrem Partner
ja da würde ich dich auch gleich noch
mal mitnehmen
hallo
merken Sie denn was das die Sarah zum
Beispiel jetzt hier in so einem Flex
Modell mitarbeitet also das davon
bekommen sie gar nichts mit ne und ich
bis jetzt noch nicht feststellen ich
durfte ja nur leider schon öfters hier
sein aber nee das ist ja gut die sollen
ja auch nichts davon merken eigentlich
ja ja das stimmt
schnaufpause einlegen
wenn wir mal einen Schritt rausgehen aus
dem Krankenhaus glaubst du dass dieses
Modell in dem du jetzt so arbeitest und
von dem du sehr profitierst auch auf
andere Branchen übertragbar wäre könnte
ich mir schon vorstellen weil du kriegst
ja zum Beispiel jetzt Mutter von einem
bei dreijährigen Kind auch
wahrscheinlich mit wie die Situation in
den Kitas ist oder ja genau wir haben
tatsächlich eine Betriebs Kita hier also
mein Sohn geht in die eigene Kita das
war damals auch der Grund warum ich hier
geblieben bin also die haben von sechs
bis 18 Uhr offen das heißt nach allem
was ich hier heute mitbekommen habe für
dich war ein Grund warum dieses
Krankenhaus dich halten konnte als
Fachkraft dass du jetzt im Flex Modell
deine Arbeitszeiten komplett frei wählen
kannst aber eben auch das ist so eine
betriebliche Kita gibt ich bin damals
nach der Elternzeit wegen der
betriebskater wieder hierher gekommen
und bin jetzt aber wegen dem Flex Modell
geblieben
ob so ein flexibles Arbeitszeitmodell
auch auf eine Kita anwendbar wäre das
müsste man erst noch ausprobieren es
zeigt sich aber dass es neue Ideen
braucht um Menschen wie Sarah und
Francesca zu entlasten
[Musik]
der Fachkräftemangel ist ein riesiges
und ein kompliziertes Problem ich habe
nicht erwartet dafür einfach Lösungen zu
finden und die Politik hat ja Maßnahmen
ergriffen aber was mir im Rahmen dieser
Reise klar geworden ist ist dass es noch
viele Jahre dauern wird bis die wirklich
greifen wenn überhaupt was es braucht
sind schnelle Lösung und die Ansätze
dafür kommen momentan eben nicht aus der
Politik sondern vor allem aus privaten
und wirtschaftlichen Initiative
betriebskater z.B oder das flexiblere
Arbeitszeitmodell an der Uniklinik
Würzburg es wäre an der Politik solche
Ansätze ganz spezifisch zu fördern und
so noch viel mehr Menschen zugänglich zu
machen auch darum geht es bei dieser
Landtagswahl ansonsten werden Fachkräfte
wie Francesca und Sarah und dadurch auch
Familien und weite Teile der
Gesellschaft immer weiter an ihre
Grenzen gebracht oder sogar darüber
hinaus
[Musik]